[Música]
[Aplausos]
llegó la hora de descubrir el verdadero
poder de un buen enjuague bucal pero
este no es cualquier enjuague bucal es
un enjuague especial es uno que se puede
tomar y que cuando nos lo tomamos nos
transforma nos ayuda a comunicar mejor
nos ayuda a acercarnos a otros con
confianza bienvenidos a un enjuague de
ideas
sabían ustedes que la mala comunicación
nos cuesta dinero un reciente estudio de
los eeuu dijo que 243 mil millones de
dólares fue el costo por comunicación
ineficaz en las empresas en un solo año
243 mil millones de dólares por jefes
que no les supieron dar bien una
instrucción a sus empleados por colegas
que no pudieron leer un mail completo y
sencillamente no supieron cuáles eran
sus tareas saben ustedes qué podemos
hacer con 243 mil millones de dólares
podríamos comprar 780 aviones
comerciales 170 mil autos de lujo
podríamos enviar a 600 mil estudiantes
con todos los gastos pagos a la mejor
universidad del mundo podríamos comprar
680 veces el mejor equipo de liga
europea o de béisbol o de basquetbol en
eeuu
si la mala comunicación nos cuesta
dinero
y no nos cuesta solo dinero una mala
comunicación nos puede costar la
relación con nuestros padres la relación
con nuestros hijos una mala comunicación
nos puede costar un trabajo
un ascenso
una mala comunicación nos puede costar
un matrimonio
piense por un momento a usted cuánto le
ha costado la mala comunicación
en un mundo de smartphones en un mundo
de mensajería instantánea en un mundo de
internet pudiéramos decir que estamos
hiperconectados pero la verdadera
pregunta es estamos bien comunicados
muchos ya hoy no piensan ni siquiera lo
que van a decir publican memes quejas
sugerencias reclamos pero no se toman el
tiempo de digerir lo que van a
reproducir lo que van a decir por eso
quiero invitarlos a una rutina muy
sencilla de 5 pasos que nos van a ayudar
a comunicar de forma saludable están
listos
el primer paso es eliminar las bacterias
del mensaje las bacterias del mensaje
voy a hacer una serie de ruidos que
muchos hacemos al hablar y quizá para
muchos de ustedes sean familiares
este
bueno
sí sí eso se llaman muletillas son
ruidos que afectan el mensaje las
muletillas son gérmenes en nuestra
comunicación y aquí los quiero invitar a
hacernos el primer enjuague
lo tragamos y nos transforma para
eliminar esas muletillas vamos a hacer
silencios vamos a empezar a hacer pausas
pausas cuando estemos hablando para
conectar una idea con otra porque las
muletillas surgen generalmente cuando
estamos desconcentrados empiecen a
hablar editado y van a ver que van a
poder dar en el blanco que otros
gérmenes tienen nuestra comunicación las
malas palabras cuanto cuesta decir una
mala palabra cuántas palabras dice usted
en un minuto y cuántas de esas son
groserías o son malas palabras elimine
las bacterias de su mensaje y aquí nos
vamos al segundo punto
use ideas refrescantes para comunicar
una idea usted tiene que pensar si su
idea vale la pena si de verdad merece un
público más amplio si tiene que ser
difundida si su idea realmente edifica
si su idea es refrescante en periodismo
solemos dar un ejemplo cuando vamos a
definir qué es noticia y que no es
noticia que es extraordinario y que no
es extraordinario y es que si un perro
muerde un niño eso no es noticia pero si
el niño muerde a un perro la cosa cambia
porque es extraordinario
sus ideas son extraordinarias los invito
al segundo enjuague
nos refresca lo tomamos y nos transforma
piensen ustedes en las cosas en las que
creen piensen en las cosas que le
apasionan piensen en las cosas que
conocen y por un momento fíjense en que
hace única esa idea
ahora exagero eso les va a permitir
comunicar ideas de forma extraordinaria
y nos vamos al tercer punto el tercer
enjuague que les propongo es el enjuague
de la claridad hable claro hable con
claridad porque muchas veces lo que
tenemos en nuestra mente por tenerlo en
nuestra mente no significa que ya el
otro nos vaya a entender perfectamente
no podemos dar lo obvio por obvio y
muchas veces nos comunicamos en un
lenguaje que no es ni sencillo ni es
universal y el otro no nos entiende les
voy a dar un ejemplo cuando la cocina a
mi casa está sucia normalmente mi esposa
suele decirme jason la cocina está sucia
y yo le digo desde el sofá sentado
viendo televisión sí mi amor el sábado
viene la señora de la limpieza no te
preocupes ella frunce el ceño se enoja y
todo el día se la pasa brava conmigo
y varias veces pasó eso y yo decía por
qué hasta que después de unos meses de
ya no querer tener más rabietas con ella
le pregunté mi amor porque reaccionas
así y ella me dijo es que me gustaría
que me ayudarás aunque sea con una tarea
de la casa como lavar los platos y ahí
descubrí que no estábamos hablando en el
mismo código que no estábamos hablando
en el mismo lenguaje y empezamos a
comunicarnos de forma directa
con suposiciones las cosas no funcionan
las suposiciones son las caries de las
ideas
usted no puede pensar que porque usted
tiene un nivel de conocimiento el otro
tiene el mismo nivel de conocimiento que
usted y aquí los invito a hacerse el
siguiente enjuague
nos refresca
y nos transforma usted tiene que hablar
en un lenguaje en el que un niño de
siete años o un hombre de 70 años le
puedan entender lo que quiere decir
usted tiene que empezar a hablar un
lenguaje universal y para ello tiene que
conocer al receptor tiene que conocer al
otro tiene que conocer al que usted le
va a comunicar su idea los periodistas
cuándo vamos a hacer una entrevista a un
gran político oa una celebridad nos
tomamos un tiempo para investigarlo para
averiguar qué le gusta
cuál es su entorno cuáles son sus
opiniones hasta si toca algún
instrumento musical todo buscando un
punto de conexión porque ese punto de
conexión nos va a permitir comunicarle
en el código correcto usted tiene que
investigar a su público a su receptor
sea su mamá sea su novia sea su hijo sea
su esposo dese cuenta en qué código
tiene que hablarle y seguro cuando usted
encuentra ese punto de conexión
construir el puente que necesita para
comunicar su idea con claridad vamos al
siguiente punto de este enjuague el
sabor burbujeante de las historias
y es que a todos nos gusta que nos
cuenten historias desde pequeños nos ha
gustado que nos cuenten relatos que nos
cuenten cuentos de hecho la mente humana
evolucionó a través de las historias
nuestros antepasados se reunían
alrededor de una fogata de una hoguera y
se contaban de generación en generación
sus anécdotas oa quien su abuelito no le
ha contado una historia que le haya
marcado la vida
es quizá por eso que las historias son
las que realmente tocan los corazones
y es que yo les pudiera hablar de una
realidad como la realidad de los
venezolanos que están migrando a
colombia y se las puedo contar de dos
formas la primera con cifras un millón
300 mil venezolanos han llegado a
colombia a junio de 2019 y si la cosa
continúa creciendo como dicen los
pronósticos el gobierno de colombia
deberá destinar el próximo año el 10 por
ciento del presupuesto nacional para
atenderlos
vamos a hacernos un enjuague
y nos transforma
yo les puedo contar esa misma realidad a
través de la historia de víctor un joven
venezolano de 20 años que perteneció al
sistema nacional de orquestas de
venezuela de donde salió el mismísimo
maestro gustavo dudamel talentoso tocaba
en los mejores teatros de su país y hoy
ha tenido que trasladarse a las frías
calles de bogotá a mostrar su talento a
la espera de una moneda a la espera de
un billete para pagar ese cuarto de tres
metros cuadrados donde intenta
sobrevivir
y esa realidad es la que toca corazones
y esa realidad es la que mueve pasiones
es la que mueve a quienes tienen el
poder es la que mueve a quienes tienen
el presupuesto para cambiar las cosas
cuenta historias las historias muestran
nuestro lado más humano
cuál es la suya
vamos al siguiente punto de este
enjuague
compartan la experiencia usted tiene que
ilustrar en los ojos de la gente lo que
usted quiere contar
hubo un pedagogo común y famoso en los
eeuu que se llama édgar de él y él
diseñó algo que se llama el cono de la
experiencia y según su teoría después de
dos semanas ustedes van a recordar sólo
el 20 por ciento de lo que escucharon
durante esta charla el 30 por ciento de
las imágenes que vieron pero como oyeron
y vieron al mismo tiempo van a recordar
el 50 por ciento de esta charla pero
para llegar al 90% él dice que hay que
demostrarlo y experimentarlo hay que
vivir la experiencia
por eso vamos a hacer no es el siguiente
enjuague
si usted empieza a leer un manual para
manejar un vehículo solo por leerlo ya
sabe manejar el vehículo
es diferente si yo lo monto usted al
vehículo le enseño dónde queda la
palanca de cambios dónde queda el
acelerador y dónde queda el freno su
proceso de aprendizaje va a ser
completamente distinto invite a esa
persona a la que usted le quiere
comunicar una idea a compartir la
experiencia viva esa experiencia con
otra persona y va a ver que nunca se le
va a olvidar y por último este es un
enjuague indicado para su uso diario
usted tiene que dejar huella en esa
persona usted tiene que hacer que esa
persona ya no vea las cosas como siempre
las ha visto que cambie su forma de
percibir las cosas que usted pueda hacer
que cada día esa persona haga un cambio
en sus hábitos después de que usted le
haya compartido esa idea como yo que
tengo que lavarla los
usted tiene que lograrlo usted tiene que
intentarlo tiene que compartir esa idea
para que sea una idea de uso diario por
eso hoy los invito a que nos hagamos
este enjuague y repasemos todos ustedes
tienen en sus manos el poder del
enjuague
vamos a tomar vamos a enjuagar nos y
luego vamos a tragar
y nos transforma
sigan todas las instrucciones de la
etiqueta de este enjuague y nunca más
van a volver a comunicar cómo
comunicaban antes si hay alguna
contraindicación repita su uso
sueño con un mundo donde personas que
tienen ideas extraordinarias puedan
comunicar las de forma extraordinaria
sueño con un mundo donde emprendedores
que necesitan vender sus proyectos que
necesitan acceder a recursos puedan
hacerlo comunicando y demostrando y
haciendo vivir la experiencia a esos
inversionistas que tienen el poder de
cambiar el mundo sueño con un mundo
donde las familias no se rompan por una
mala comunicación recuerde usted tiene
el enjuague en sus manos usted es el
director de su propia historia y ahora
que se ha enjuagado sonríe recuerde
usted también puede comunicar y puede
hacerlo bien muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]